let me draw a random polygon a polygon
is a closed figure with three or more
sides and we have another polygon here
are these two figures congruent well
they look like each other but the
condition for congruence says that these
two figures are congruent if one when
placed on the other they both should
overlap exactly if we move this one over
the first one we can see that it
overlaps exactly it means they are
congruent figures let's erase this and
draw another polygon and here's another
one are these two figures congruent at
first they don't look congruent but
that's the trick this polygon when
placed on this one overlaps exactly so
they are congruent two doesn't matter
how they are placed
that's congruence but let's understand a
bit more about congruence when are two
figures congruent it's simple they
should have the same shape as well as
the same size say we have a shape like
this and another one like this we can
easily say that they are not congruent
as they're completely different shapes
now look at this shape and this one we
can see that the shape is the same but
wait the sizes are different which is
why these two figures are also not
congruent but what about these two
shapes they have the same shape as well
as the same size they are congruent
figures but we cannot place a figure on
the other to know if they are congruent
or not so how can we say if two figures
are congruent or not we need to
understand a simple concept first is it
only figures that can be congruent
consider two segments segment a B and
segment CD both measure 3 units can we
say that they are congruent of course we
can segment
a B is congruent to segment CD what if
we have two angles like this with the
same measure they both measure 60
degrees yes these two angles are also
congruent coming back to a question when
are two figures congruent look at these
two triangles when can we say that they
are congruent we can say that these two
triangles are congruent
if all the matching sites and all the
matching angles are congruent we will
understand more about congruence of
triangles in the coming videos
you